The vertex of the equation y plus 3 equals the quantity x minus two squared is
that two comma negative 3, this point down here. Even though I didn't give you
the graph, you could figure this out, by thinking about how this graph is
shifted away from the graph of y equals x squared. Here's a quick hand-drawn
version, not very spectacular I'm sorry, of y equals x squared. Our point of
reference are our parent problem. Since we already knew that the red curve would
be just an exact shift of the black curve to the right 2 and down 3. We can pick
any point on the black curve and find the corresponding point on the red curve.
We can do this for the vertex, which is originally at 0, 0 on the black curve.
So then if we move it to the right 2, the x coordinate becomes 2. And if we move
it down 3, the y coordinate becomes negative 3.